hello everyone welcome to another world
from language designer view this is part
of our language completeness and
consistency series
and we have a variety of um
uh
topics
knitting for terminated evaluation and
propagated boards so do I have to be in
13 2 yes I do so I need to move this
into 13 2.
does it help me in 13-2
that's very confusing well okay
there I've got 13 2
and let me go to um let me open doc
tools here
uh do I have to update documentation no
I have not made any changes in fact I
was so uncertain about uh
um
I guess uh
propagated the boards that I think I uh
no probably the boards was the easier
one right I'm confused I just remember
that I've made I've not put anything in
the in the docs yet so
wait a minute is
I mean there are rough pages but I
haven't put anything on any guide page I
haven't I I have no I have some
suggestions if you open up the section
but I have not
uh you know these these Pages were
deuterized like before the Tech
Conference
let me remind myself what propagate
about it's even his
it controls the behavior of checkerboard
when
you know
whether it you know it kills off the
abort or
uh you know handles the abort but then
lets it to persist to be caught by some
higher level shouldn't this point to
confirm and close and also point to the
event handler stuff
I don't think the this should point to
event handler uh confirm and close uh I
I suppose I mean I don't think confirm
and close support this and I'm not sure
that they should no I understand that I
understand that but what I'm saying is
part of the point of a sea also is you
got to this page by hook or crook
but this might be not the page you were
looking for so to speak
point you to what you might have been
looking for and that's why I think event
handler isn't irrelevant to this
okay
Handler is totally different isn't it
yeah it is but it has this notion of
doesn't it have an option for passing up
and passing down events
uh
probably
um
Brett do you know I I mean that's more
of a John and Lou question who are not
here
um
I mean there's
some control in that in an event handler
and I forget what it is it's yeah past
events down past events up yes
okay
yeah I mean at least those should point
to propagated bullets okay
um that's right those are those are very
directly analogous even though they're
in a very different context yep okay
so
I don't know what's on the flow control
page let me take a look
you think it goes right after a board
protect there yep
okay looks fine to me
how do I how do I get this guy triple
click copy and paste it into the search
bar
well you didn't select the whole thing
but that'll work
um okay what do you think here
so
um
all right I guess it goes into low level
error but clearly a representation
surely this should have
um
permanent evaluation should be part of
that
okay
at the end
okay Avery are you taking notes on all
these locations so I'll remember after
yes we can meet Friday yep
okay
um
now propagate
oh it goes down here right
just protect yep okay
um
let's see this thing yeah
right so we have uh checkerboard under
evaluation
um
bullet proofing
so I'm not sure if it should go at the
end because it's right it sort of
affects how checkerboards interacts with
time constraint and memory constraint
those are really sort of the main use
case all right put it at the end of that
line I would say
yeah
um
okay
right and if you if you notice the
question marks those uh represent my my
level of confidence
foreign
I mean it seems like yeah
it seems like it should go in that
section but I don't know if we want it
just as a bullet point or if we want the
one function indicator listing
with some description
it's kind of weird because the user will
never type it in
I guess that's true
unlike everything else on this page
[Music]
correct
um I think we wanted on a okay hold on
I mean it just feels wrong well
no it's okay
fine you should just have terminated
evaluation
um
representation
what do you say about it
has been stopped for the specified
region I don't think that is oh that
that I uh
oh that
um
okay that ha oh well I guess okay I
would make it past perfect if we're
going to go with past tense so has been
where that was stopped for the specified
reason okay but you know what we need to
give the sense that this is
a global reason so to speak
okay
um
thank you
hmm
represents
I would even say an evaluation process
that has been
you know what why don't we look what
doesn't
because it's it's it's a tentacle of the
evaluation
right uh and I mean this is going in a
slightly different direction though we
could say something represents an
expression whose evaluation was
terminated for the specified reason
yes that's good actually
who's evaluation
I would go with simple past in this case
no no hold on a second hold on a second
whose evaluation overran Global limits
and was terminated
okay
Global session global
um
system limits well the system suggests
it's external
yeah that might be I I would say session
or kernel session just to sort of be
clear what
um
I think that's a bit clearer about what
kind of a thing this is
[Music]
whose evaluation well represents an
expression
okay
so then here
we would say
um
and here we'd say terminate evaluation
by the way it's not necessarily a global
session on this doesn't time constrained
does it return I mean that that is
what's weird because time constraint and
memory constrained aren't sort of global
things right okay so peppered anywhere
so in a sense those are sort of the odd
odd ones in that but but they they now
return terminated valuation right no
oh I see okay so why don't they because
they might
uh because well for one thing you can
control what what is the return value of
uh I see that's a good point and and
right and it's generating a literal
abort so if you don't specify anything
it returns okay listen you should also
put in here something about how
uh you know terminate evaluation is kind
of deadly and you can't do anything with
it so to speak
okay if you have suggestions on how to
put that in all ears
um I don't understand why you don't just
start with x equals X plus one here
uh I like down value functions but why
don't we start with x equals X plus one
it's really the simplest minimal case
um
what can you not do with the terminated
evaluation
presumably you can't assign a value to
terminated evaluation
or can you you can replace for it
I mean in principle right it's a normal
expression right I mean that literally
is I mean at the present time I mean
well because we haven't packed the other
stuff into it right
so at uh you know at the present time
this is just symbol of string I mean
once we add to it we'll have also have
the expert struct and right you yeah
okay it's per struck but that's
potentially dangerous depending on if
you try to actually okay so why don't we
just figure out what we're going to say
here so terminated evaluation
[Music]
um
something like the
um
representation
um we could just say something generated
by exceeding Global limits and then yeah
you know well we could say say
um
representation
let's see
it's not a result
because it isn't the result
um
I mean it's a substitute for solar an
evaluation terminated by global limits
but something like that donut evaluation
Dash and evaluation terminated by global
limits
your Global limits what's that maybe
exceeding Global limits
would be clear
instead of just by global limit I'm
suggesting by exceeding
no but it wasn't terminated by exceeding
terminated as a result of exceeding okay
which is going to get too long
terminated due to global limits yeah
that's what I was about to suggest
I think that's fine
it's a perfect reasonable thing for this
page let me just send that
to you guys I'm not I'm not going to
edit that page
okay
yep I got it thank you
and I need to push back that
documentation update in a minute
um
from here
um
right so one question is if if the C
also should also include things you know
like
dollar failed and failure I think it
should include failure at least
I would put that at the end
um
I think you really do need to say more
about the semantics of this thing
although maybe we don't need to write
much more until we have a richer version
okay let's take a look at some of these
other ones
right I don't think so well failure
representations right that's exactly
what I was thinking
yeah why not at the end of that list
terminated evaluation okay
um right okay because it includes
Stellar iteration limits so I was
wondering if it should go there but you
know like I said I put two question
marks so yeah I don't I don't buy that
one okay
and I think memory uh optimization
probably includes dollar recursion
limits so uh was uh yeah oh both both of
them which is yeah yeah
um okay question let me just think about
this for a second
where do we have so we have evaluation
control uh
see in a sense terminated evaluation by
the way it should have
let me just say if we've got keywords
oh I forgot keywords
infinite recursion
infinite expressions
um
maybe uncontrolled iteration
is anybody ever going to type that in
um we should we should have at least
some version of iteration on there yeah
I know but
unbounded iteration
yeah that probably sounds better
well but that might mean something
different I mean
unbounded iteration could mean do with
infinity
mm-hmm I think gun control is better
uh
I don't know what else okay is there a
guide page about
about expressions
that takes us there
but only answer it should be on this
page
um
well I guess it's uh
[Music]
um
I I think I I don't know that there's
anything
uncontroversial uncontroversial that
goes on the space there are plenty of
controversial things right like graph
right it's
it's not right you can't operate it on
it like a normal expression and it is
backed by a raw expert but I don't know
that people really think of it as an
atomic thing
we could have a section on this page
that lists some of those kinds of things
um
okay
all right
uh let me just push that before I forget
okay
Nick is now
instituting so
I don't see why you shouldn't join us as
a visitor here but
ah
oh Nick's not here this time I didn't
realize that right I think it's because
he's now officially part of the
Institute
and so who knows whether he even got the
notification properly
uh
okay well I think I I well then I think
we should just
but we started this conversation last
time and well I guess the One update I
can give is you know it's probably not
super hard to to change the behavior to
be what next one what Nick wants the
question is is that the right thing and
what sort of collateral damage would we
incur by making is it something that
didn't match previously
no no it's it's so it's cases where you
have an unused ver you know you have a
variable that I see unused branch of
right and so what is that thing when
it's unused correct
and it could be just like our terminated
expression it could be an unmatched
pattern
it could be a symbolic thing unmatched
pattern well that would be very
backwards incompatible
yeah
um I mean if we if we made it uh you
know literally sequence bracket bracket
then you wouldn't see any different if
you difference if you substituted it
into
something that isn't hold hold all or I
mean hold complete or sequence hold
um could we is it it's the latter that
I'm worried about to be honest I wanted
I wanted to
um
tests to see what that would do to Alpha
yeah I've got another suggestion come
Brenton's code analysis tools perhaps
look for this case and just show us what
people have actually done
um
oh it's can we write a meta pattern
that looks for patterns like this in our
code base
right well I mean I can certainly tell
you that things that I've done I mean
obviously this is a super contrived case
but right
um right you know check like if hold
complete of thing is equal to hold com
you know is same cue to hold complete
bracket bracket
and then I know if I'm in the branch
where that thing was actually used or
not
um
that is very hacky
it's very hacky but it's worked for 33
years
or I guess
30 years right because you needed to get
all time 25 years because I don't think
we had to hold complete until version
three so it's worked for 25 years
okay well I think we need Nick to
further represent this yeah
Geo range Ro world
so
um
there's the question
um
yes so the question here is that when we
say world
it's World from minus 180
to Plus 180. and in some emails you said
you seem to be suggesting that we should
adapt to the local position centering at
the local position
it's like I remember when I first went
to Australia at the airport they were
selling uh you know upside down Maps
right which which I'm sure is just a
joke but um so what is don't we already
have a distinction between like Geo
range world and I forgot it was like
gear range full or all or something like
that but one of them centers at zero
zero and the other just centers it we
have a secret we have a secret string
called
adjusted world
that centers at your location
all and I'm not sure about full but
certainly all is basically a synonym for
world correct correct
well but I thought all that maybe I
misremembered but I thought all didn't
like if you do a projection that covers
the whole earth like you know equal
rectangular or something I thought all
didn't always Center it at zero zero but
world did
or maybe I'm wrong I think unless I've
forgotten about that change I think both
world and all centered at zero zero by
default right yeah I mean that depends
on the value of geocenter right which is
obviously what I've
is your Center can't override that but I
think the idea originally was that most
people are used to the map of the world
that centers at zero zero
nope we're going to be able to make
those Geo tiles faster
oh did this change now
so right because you you wanted all
these style changes right so I evaluated
that example a few weeks ago so oh I see
but if I go here
this is this is my version 13 2. so all
does this this is what I'm saying all
will force centering at zero zero
and so what we are discussing is that
all says I want the whole world but
centered at whatever the first argument
is suggesting right so right so I guess
the question is what what does the
combination Geo range goes to all
geocentric go to automatic do where does
that Center things yeah I understand and
if there's content in the Geographics
does it take accounts of the content
so in central to this string adjusted
world
right so the discussion is whether all
should do that
or whether we document a string
I think we were never happy with this
one
well I think okay what do you do if
you've got Israel and it's anti-poed
both in the first argument
so that that I well I guess Jose can
tell me but I will try to guess right so
it will right it tries to find the
center of all the things you've given it
so if it'll the whole world it would
just pick zero zero presumably
so
let's see because this is forcing the
orthographic projection it may actually
decide to Center at the middle of those
two points
but oh okay if this was like uh the
standard rectangular projection it would
show both points and try to Center both
parts
okay so that went halfway in between
exactly that's not completely stupid
what that did
yes but this is because you you still
have adjusted wall if you had had all or
walled it was hard Force minus 180 280.
right and of course with an
equirectangular projection it only it
picks the center of the longitude
because the latitude is is fixed by the
projection
foreign
if you want a really hard case you
should do you know Geo you should do
point of random geoposition of 100 or
something like that
right
okay
I mean to be honest though there's
nothing good it can do in that case
right yeah I think on some level I would
say that's probably an easy case because
it's basically the whole world right so
yeah so nobody I'm saying if you do say
a projection that doesn't cover the
whole world oh I see like an
orthographic projection or something
who knows I mean because the measure
this geo-random geoposition is
presumably putting more I mean it looks
like it's putting more things at the
poles here and it probably is because
that that you the projected area this is
taking more than putting yeah I think it
does it and it does it no nobody I think
oh usually in the orthographic
projection I mean random geopositions
should be sampling in an equal area
projection no exactly exactly but what
I'm saying is it looks like there's more
things at the polls because the polls
are scrunched up in this projection oh
sure there's a more General point though
if you run that again of course it's
going to Center somewhere totally random
well because these points are
homogeneously distributed the average
tends to be near zero zero right exactly
that's that's why oh I see because it's
Computing the average exactly it's
Computing average in like an equal
rectangular projection or something like
that exactly I see okay
I mean if the points were all
accumulated in some region it would
detect that and it would Center it down
richer
so you could have situations I mean
maybe you could have it in the Geo
marker case as well where you have two
points that are right across from the
International Date Line from each other
and then it centers in on zero zero on
the other side of the Earth because
their average longitude is zero no no
that's what I'm saying if the points are
close together it will detect it
oh I see okay
there it is to follow us and um
uh
okay so so the basic point is
when you do the average
is an average done in lat long
effectively
it's not an average done the projected
Geo grid position of the projection
correct no how this works is that it
takes the points constructs 3D vectors
that's the average in the 3D World and
projects back I see
because it doesn't you don't know for
example an orthographic projection the
geogrid positions are going to be
totally different depending on what
geocenter you use
yeah I see I see I see I see so I
couldn't do that okay fine fine so it's
taking the actual XYZ thing okay so now
let's let's go back to the question
so
what does Geo range so gear range
automatic would just zoom in on those
things is that correct exactly
this downloading geotiles thing it's
just crazy I mean
okay
nice nice picture though
it looks nice and
uh
okay
does Geo rage fall do anything different
no I don't think so
I think full all and world can't really
do the very same thing
and the need for this alternative
version
was realized and that's why we created
this adjusted world but it's not
documented so we I think we could first
introduce either this string as it is or
a better name
because the need is there same world
centered or something like that
yeah I keep wondering if this is the
world after it's seen its chiropractor
okay
um
what about changing gear range all to be
this thing that takes the content
because I just worry that there are
projections where you might just not
even see the content
I think this idea that it takes the
content and centers
and the content is not silly for geo
range or
okay so
okay wait a minute but what we really
want is it's Geo range
it's sort of fixed world
as opposed to a rotating world so to
speak
well I think Walt should stay as it is
because there we use it in our in many
places and it would change it it could
change many Maps now the thing with all
is that we had decided that for planets
other than the earth it doesn't feel
very natural to say diorential oils to
world and we tend to use their range
goes to all
I see so if we change the behavior of
all we might change some out of Earth
maps
perhaps it's not so bad but I mean and
we don't recognize the surface of Mars
as as well as
the surface of the Earth well I mean
what what would happen is in the Moon
for example
orthographic projection of the moon will
show part of The Far Side
right right now if I say
[Music]
um
okay so here not that necessarily
matters but but um
I probably have to do the points in red
or something
well yeah does geomarker your geomarker
will work
um and then I say
who knows is that only no that's not
right that's not what the Moon looks
like all right well again you have an
adjusted world I know that I I know that
I know that I know that but I'm saying
that's not in the case of the Moon
what the heck
it's close but
oh I see that's just a tiny tiny bit off
it's like like Liberation or whatever of
the moon or something
so another question is would adjusted
world because I remember well
I remember Jose you were demoing that
the Tech conference at least for sort of
in the context of Astro stuff doing I
forget what it's called we're basically
doing projections you know like
rectangular projections and so on but
where you you shift the the zero for
latitude as well I mean what adjusted
world do stuff like that or or no it
only moved longitudes in in most cases
yeah so you're referring to obliqueness
um so right now the asymmetal
projections like orthographic can go to
any world can sorry to any point can
have centering anywhere but the
cylindrical projections cannot
eventually they will be able once we
have publicness
but but yes this is a piece of
functionality that in which
in which Aster is more advanced than you
well because I guess there's already
Logic for determining you know if you
pick uh you know a non-cylindrical
projection there's already Logic for
choosing
the latitude so I guess okay so I guess
this isn't uh this is a solved problem
probably
okay what
other settings
do we have I mean so
what we've got this kind of
Geo range standard or something like
standard means Centron 0 0.
which would then work for the moon and
things as well
is it always
I see it's not actually the range or it
might be the range if the if the
projection is not is not a complete
projection so to speak
what do you mean
I mean if the projection doesn't show
everything like this orthographic case
yes but nearly all projections tend to
Center at zero zero
projections tend to Center at 0 0 by
default
okay but but this is
avoiding that centering by setting a Geo
range that depends on I mean maybe we
should have Geo range Arrow inherited or
something be the thing that takes it
from the actual values
and your range all stay where it is
right now
I mean I oh right but have you explained
them the difference between inherited
and automatic right
I mean I guess inherited is the whole
thing but why not use something like
full yeah I was wondering that too okay
well which is full and which is all then
I mean I I would prefer all to be this
thing that centers on things that you
actually can you know make sure you can
see what you need to see
um
that's fine with me as I said only a few
maps of the Moon and Mars might change
a bit but
I think that that's right okay so then
then the idea will be full means
the full planet
with its generic centering and all means
you know
I mean it's a little bit funky but it
seems okay
um
I think we should make this we should
allow this distinction so so then we're
saying gear rental changes its meaning
Geo range full
says it will always be in the standard
centering
correct yep so right now if you look at
the rough page for geo range it says
that full and all are equivalent but the
world is documented
right so all is region corresponding to
the entire world is included whereas
world is use bounding box of whole world
and I'm not even sure what that's trying
to
uh are used in Geographics what the hell
does full mean not when used in
Geographics
I don't remember whether this is just
saying this is all right I see you have
to well okay so I'm not sure so I'm not
sure about that point but actually
looking at the first note right that
explains that all in full are in fact
the same thing as World
um so we'll need to update that note too
but they can also be used in one of the
two slots whereas world can't right you
can't do the list World comma whatever
but you can't do the list all comma
whatever well I might support that for
all but not really mention it for full
this is pretty confusing and then I
think we should just deprecate World
here
sorry well
why do we need the thing world if we've
got all
right we can have it why not I I think
it's important to keep it because it's
used a lot we use a lot more world than
all
all right fine
what about planet
The Entity
or oh yeah I think it's adjusting the
string Planet as a substitute for World
Florida it's silly it's silly it's silly
it's going into planetary before it's
time
um
I do think you should support oh yeah
you do support an entity
yes okay but what happens if that entity
is Mars
well unless nothing else conflicts with
that entity I think we'll understand
that you want to go to Mars
so that case might complain that you
have something
on the moon
no it says but I think it's wrong I
think it needs to support that yeah it
should well but you also is is that
because what happens if you put an empty
list in the first
or you know uh just some Geo position
because I wonder if it's the conflict
between the Moon and Mars there
we're in the Pacific so that's about no
the Atlantic actually
um
yeah it should support that entry okay
all right I think you can write a
country there and it will understand it
but
it's not understanding I I get it yeah I
get it minor issue I mean it should
support consonants it should support
does it support consonants
um probably continuous yes
beautiful
does that surprise that I see it cut
itself off because it's orthographic and
it's only showing Asia fascinating
exactly it realize it doesn't have to go
beyond
okay nice all right so full in all and
some changing of documentation and we
leave world and what world would do is
equivalent to
foot
fine
okay
our last topic
right so you put in a request for an
operator form of divisible
um
and so sort of my my general point was
that a few if any math mathi functions
have operator forms but uh
you know if if we look at things sort of
nearby you know we can probably do
divisible if we think of this visible as
an extent the operator form of in of
divisible as an extension of even q and
odd queue then I guess this makes uh you
know you know there's no problem to
doing it there's sort of a problem doing
any of the you know most of the nearby
um like mod does mod have an operator
form
uh mod does not have an operator yeah
but it will be a mess in an operator
form right because of because of the
offset right so you couldn't do the
offset
um and you know co-prime Q for example
is zavara's including you know the
uh one I basically one identity so we
couldn't have a yeah I agree I
understand
so if you really want the visible I
don't see a problem with it but but it
would just be a little odd given
well what do other people think
I I don't see any problem having it I
think we have tended not to add so many
operative forms in mathematical
functions
yeah that's because they particularly
when they go their rocks
yeah there have been several times well
yeah I mean I I I've I've wanted an
operator form for divisible before
although I I you know every time I use
divisible I also have to look up what
the argument order is but that's yeah
yeah well that's right because because
but if you hadn't operated form you
wouldn't have to look up the argument
order
I guess because
exactly you need to know
um whether you're constructing the right
operator
okay but nobody in their right mind
would make the operator form not be if I
say divisible 5 of 10 it means is 10
divisible by 5. yeah I mean I think that
is pretty clear
right it's it's the idea it's the it's
the it's the ideal generated by the
first argument of the head right
sure it's going to argue that maybe the
argument in order but I don't think well
I'm gonna argue that it should have been
called divisible by or divides or
something like that but it's too late
now
thank you
yeah
I think we should have this operator
form I think it will it will save
because I have to look it up every
single time as well
the argument order
so okay
all right do we get through the agenda
we did
excellent
thanks thanks a lot well we'll have to
figure out how next time we want to
discuss the the things to make sure that
Nick actually knows and makes it I
didn't realize that there was this
technical change or yeah foreign
okay sounds good see you later okay bye
bye bye